joining us from the I guess the
mountains of Napa California he is
Maurice jones-drew how are you mg D rich
how are you sorry about that I was
trying to in order for me to get the map
but I got a cut through some mountains
okay so it's all good
are you bringing socks and slippers and
boots to Antonio Brown for his
cryotherapy mjd are you bringing those
yet you know yeah I read the story and
we know antennae Browns like a workout
warrior just takes care of herself and I
figured he was trying something new
because he's always about you know
figuring out a way to push yourself
further and recovering better but no I'm
not bringing socks boots or anything I
said that that looked nasty so this is
gotta let him take care about where does
this rank I mean I can't believe that he
and I'm sure the Raiders must be losing
their minds too because there really is
no I don't think there's any sort of
measuring stick or precedents to figure
out when somebody comes back from
frostbite in August right yeah yeah
right like I don't I don't know so
yesterday I was trying to get a gauge
for it he's truly missed there I can
tell you that much
but I think this is an opportunity for a
lot of other people but yeah they're
frustrated right now because they saw
they only got a taste of what he could
do in OTAs and they loved it and they're
like we need him back out here as soon
as possible but I guess he came out a
couple like earlier in the week or last
week and did two really good days but
then his feet started to mess up a lot
um again so what kind of sea I'll dig
around a little bit and I'll text you
and kind of give you a heads up so you
could talk on your show tomorrow about
it there you go
I really appreciate that and so what are
you looking for we got eleven games
tonight what are you looking forward to
seeing in week one of the preseason I'll
just throw that out in general today
well I think one way to see the young
quarterbacks that have been drafted
least most of them right we saw drew
lock on Hall of Fame night he's a little
skittish but we were kind of expecting
that I've seen from Coach banjo still
but to see kind of Murray perform to see
do the quarterback from Duke Gail Jones
perform to get opportunity Haskins
perform as well all those places are
going to be places that I'm excited to
see people perform and this how they
play really to me there's you know we
know this is a quarterback driven league
so I want to make sure these young
quarterbacks are coming in there
can you carry the load of these teams so
we'll see from there and and of course
we'll see who is playing and who is not
is Todd Gurley playing in the first
preseason game for the Rams yeah I don't
think girls don't play in any preseason
games we were joking last year I know
you were in the Hills here in the hills
get into reception I was we were Kristin
Brockman and I were talking if you would
answer that question with laughter or
with an actual real response you know
right oh this is funny I'm about to get
checked right now for my parking passes
I'm pulling up to the hotel right now
okay make sure you do that walk blood
says Maurice jones-drew
his face you say your face is your
identification Maurice see how that
works okay okay there we go this part
look attached that is inside training
camp big time right there tell me about
what is going on with Gurley come on now
I can't get there's happening with him
there's nothing going on with girl he
looks phenomenal out here he's running
well cutting he's doing everything again
a lot of this was it is called my
contract maintenance if I pay someone
you know X amount of dollars I want him
to fulfill his whole contract I don't
want to just get half of the contract I
just don't want to get 1/3 of the
contract I want to make sure that we get
every all the years and all the money
that we put into him and so for Todd
going out and getting gerald Henderson
the the plan they put him on this year
it's all about preserving them for the
the marathon of the season yes and
that's important because we saw last
year he started getting a ton of carries
and then Malcolm Brown goes down who's
his dispell guy and then all of a sudden
there is no second back they only kept
two backs up the whole time so it's
gonna be it's gonna be very interesting
to see how it works out but I think it's
gonna be for the betterment of Todd girl
and his longevity no there's no doubt
about that it's just that you know there
was no contract management required in
January and I know he ran roughshod all
over the Cowboys but we just saw way too
much of somebody other than Todd Gurley
and certainly in an NFC Championship
game where things weren't working out so
how much girl I mean are we gonna see
60% 50% half of the carries that girly
had all season long and yeah this is a
lot to do with what people are doing or
thinking about with their fantasy
football but yeah you know but what what
Gurley are we gonna see Maurice I think
girl he's gonna get the same carries in
the same touches personally that's what
I'm hearing
I just think that plays where Todd was
on the field and he wasn't touching the
ball they're gonna try to use Darryl
Henderson and Malcolm Brown more for
that so I still think he carries the
ball 280 300 times but all those extra
plays that he was just on the field and
not you know not being able to they
weren't able to like get him
I'm sorry is playing like so the place
where he was pass blocking there's no
reason for him to be in there we can put
someone else in there for that you know
and I still think he's going to get
utilized the way because this offense
runs through Todd Gurley now you're
going to talk about the championship
game the NFC champion game he just woke
up on the wrong side of the bed to be
honest with you and we had a bad game
and so in that type of game make coach
McVeigh pulled um understanding that
okay this is an important game he's
having a bad game he dropped the pass
that led to a pick he really wasn't
running like we saw so they went with CJ
Anderson who really didn't run that well
either in the energy temperature game
when you get to the Super Bowl it's
about the same way
I think Todd had a couple good runs but
it wasn't consistent enough for McVeigh
and so he wanted to go out and try to
open the running game up by throwing the
ball first so that's kind of how it was
Maurice jones-drew here on the Rich
Eisen show and Gurley looms over the
entire running back scene right now
because of his contract
and we're seeing two guys sitting out
one in Cabo one where I don't know where
Melvin Gordon is what advice would you
give to Melvin Gordon right now because
the Zeke situation and Gordon's are
different and they're different from
Le'Veon bells was last year right what
do you what advice would you give Melvin
Gordon right now
Maurice continue to stay in shape you
know I think the charges are going to
wake up and understand that his Philip
Rivers gets older he needs he needs
someone to garnish that eight-man box
those receivers as good as they are
remember they're going against
one-on-one covers on the outside talking
with a lot of people just around we went
to Chargers Rams camp a lot of people
are you know a lot of people are
optimistic that hopefully they can try
to get something done but let's remember
they have depth because of Melvin Gordon
not not they have depth without Melvin
Gordon right so they need to make sure
that I'm watching those practices their
running game wasn't that good and so you
want to make sure that you have your
top-notch player they're ready to go
it's important that that happens if it's
if that doesn't happen you know I don't
see the Chargers winning eight games
without Melvin Gordon to be honest with
you that's 1200 yards double-digit
touchdowns the last three years even
when they missing games he's still
giving you 1200 and 10 to 12 plus
touchdowns who's gonna replace that
would you counsel them to still stay out
though - literally withhold his services
oh yeah because again you know you
performed and we know how many guys have
we seen and can't get hurt right and if
you're going for a contract you got to
make sure that you know you're your
number one your first priority is to be
healthy so that the team pays you if you
are out there and you get hurt in
training camp there's no way the team is
going to pay you anyways so all I can
tell them is is while you're out being
trained as hard as you can to be in the
best shape possible so when you come
back you can you know you'll have an
impact on the game but during training
camp I'm not going to go out there and
risk risk injury when I know there's a
situation where either you know we could
get something done or not now I don't
know how it's going to go into the
season I know Zeke is talking about he's
not going to play the rest of the C's
and all those things about that yeah
just right that's his choice to do that
but with Melvin Gordon I mean the
charges are so close you would think
that they would try to get it done
sooner than later because automatically
as good as he is he's only as good as he
is when he comes in and spells Melvin
Gordon's well I'm Jackson yeah no no I
know what you're saying but Zeke is Zeke
is also on a team that that's ready to
win the Super Bowl they're so close to
and you know we spent all last year this
time talking about Le'Veon Bell who
unlike these two guys wasn't under
contract and he just wasn't gonna sign
his franchise tender he wanted something
that the chart Steelers after mid-july
couldn't give him right because once you
get past a certain point you're not
allowed to negotiate a long-term deal
and then it all came down to it Bell
signed a contract that did not surpass
Todd Girly's and we had Stephen Jones
the CEO of the Cowboys on yesterday and
he has absolutely pointed out in the
same way that will you wait to sign a
player and the players at a position
that has now a new benchmark elsewhere
set for a contract you know you're gonna
have to surpass that the conversely it
seems like Bell reset the market lower
than Gurley and that counts against Zeke
I'm not really I wouldn't say that I
would say yeah I remember Todd Gurley
signed his deal at 23 right so it's
different Le'Veon signed his deal at 27
so he's your you know age wise you're
gonna give more money to a younger
player obviously in that situation
for me when you talk about Ezekiel
Elliott and this is where I kind of get
frustrated with people because we'll pay
quarterbacks who aren't worse they're
there their price and we'll just say
well he's the quarterback we got to pay
him but when I'm running back when your
team has really built around this one
player all of a sudden it's like why I
don't know so for example let's use the
Cowboys this was brought up to me
yesterday and it's a great point who's
more important to
the Cowboys Ezekiel elevator dak
Prescott
there's no question right peak right I
would say so yes I would say although
you know if your backup quarterback may
not be as good as dak but go uh let's
just wait keep going though well do the
exercise okay so Zeke is looking for a
contract from in the 13 to 15 million
dollar range you you're telling me that
you're gonna end up paying Dec 30
million dollars twice as much as Zeke
and you're not gonna blink a higher deck
but you're the blinking eye at execu
Elliott like that makes zero sense to me
where does this make in business where
does this make sense of this player if
you know this player is a guy that helps
you in games and does everything for you
and you know we because we have we have
stats to back it up that when Zeke is
playing when Zeke is playing they win
games when Zeke is not playing guess
what they don't win games so you're
gonna argue and say well you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna fight as EQ Elliott
to give him what he's what he's really
worth to this organization to this team
but I'm gonna go ahead and hand his
other money to someone else and I'm not
saying that Dave Prescott isn't worth
the 30 million dollars but I know for
sure that Zeke is worth 15 I can I know
that by because when he's on the field
you win games when he's not on the field
like when you guys are spending for six
games you lose games and you don't make
the playoffs and you don't do these
different things that you do when he's
in so when it comes down to it you can't
look at you know Le'Veon Bell situation
even though I can use his situation and
say well Pittsburgh can have lady on
bill and when lady on Bell is on the
field they won 10-digit they've won
double-digit games every year when he's
not on the field they go 8 7 & 1 so I
don't know is he important I don't know
but in these situations when you talk
about the running back position like
Melvin Gordon and in the zql it and
other players that will be coming out
like Alvin Kamara in the near future and
some other players out there
Joe mix-ins another guy that should be
looking to get paid teams know that you
can't win without a without a
that garnishes eight-man boxes because
you have to make it easy for your
quarterback to help read coverages and
help help him out but we'll pay some of
these quarterbacks buku money 30 million
a year this and that and they're not
worth it
but it's because the position it's the
market value for the position
that's a horrible excuse if he's not
worth 30 million dollars don't ruin your
your your your cap and your team for a
kid that's not worth it you have a
running back that's worth 15 million
dollars and he helps you win you should
pay him fifteen million dollars man do
it no it's you and Marshall and Eric
Dickerson all you running backs you
sound the same you're saying the same
thing about the court organization runs
through the running back pay em it's
real simple
yeah amazing you're the man MJD you
callin the radio or TV or you hear you I
know you were to Siciliano we saw you
running up the hill and getting getting
beat by Siciliano right
and Tiffany Blackman he we saw that well
hold on reg Tiffany Blackman almost hurt
me first and foremost okay push me push
me oh okay I haven't like I'm like you
know I'm not you know seeing zero
contact we see there were no Flags no no
looking at the video that was great
Instagram right here where Sid no you
know she tried to she tried to push me
you got to see the out of you you have
to see that of you that stabbed you as a
matter what I get the other view for you
you could have fit Siciliano in between
the two of you that's how far apart you
were I was set up cuz I ran up the hill
I got it let me break this down to the
people first I'd ran up the hill twice
before that already then they wanted to
come down and do it a third time that's
tough I was a little winded the lactic
acid was flowing I'm sure I'm sure
good chat with the mjd will help to say
I hope to see you soon now have a good
day that's a
at mjd on twitter maurice jones-drew for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app